[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle de ces
solutions pour sauver la planète
applicable tout de suite pour peu que
les politiques s'en donnent les moyens
des innovations portées par nos PME nos
startups qui peuvent nous permettre non
pas dans 10 ans mais dès maintenant de
réduire notre consommation énergétique
et notre impact carbone le tout dans une
logique de rentabilité économique
bonjour Bertrand Picard bonjour de vous
avoir dans cette émission
on vous présente plus mais on fait quand
même vous êtes le premier homme à avoir
eu cette chance de faire le tour du
monde à bord d'un avion propulsé
uniquement l'énergie solaire le célèbre
solar RIM pulse c'est aussi la Fondation
votre fondation qui recense depuis 2003
les solutions techniques les plus
rentables les plus propres services de
l'environnement puis un nouveau combat
c'est votre combat actuel c'est cette
campagne donc de prête à voter que vous
avez lancé pour accélérer la transition
énergétique en France il y a vraiment
urgence en même temps quand on lit
dernier rapport du GIEC on se dit oui il
faut accélérer là alors il y a urgence
il y a beaucoup de problèmes une fois
que vous avez dit ça vous décourager
tout le monde parce que vous parce que
tout le monde a pensé que le problème
est trop gros pour qu'on puisse agir
donc moi j'ai essayé d'inverser la chose
et de parler davantage de solutions que
de problème et de montrer que on peut
répondre à l'urgence par le fait que des
solutions soient économiquement
rentables soit attrayantes soit
créatrice d'emploi soit enthousiasmante
alors on a cherché avec la Fondation
Solar Impulse combien il y en avait dans
le monde on en a trouvé jusqu'à
maintenant 1500
1486 et ces solutions sont à disposition
mais ne sont pas utilisées même si elles
sont économiquement rentables et on a
regardé pourquoi et on a pris en France
50 solutions qui auraient vraiment un
bénéfice magnifique pour des carboner et
on a demandé aux innovateurs ce qui les
bloquait et nous ont donné des
obstacles réglementaires des obstacles
législatifs etc ce fait qu'on a demandé
un cabinet d'avocat de tourner tous ces
problèmes en recommandation de
changement de législatif et on a sorti
ce prêt à voter c'est pas un livre
amusant à lire pour des noms
spécialistes mais c'est 5 autres
recommandations de législatives pour les
parlementaires de manière à débloquer
les obstacles qui jusqu'à maintenant
empêcher des solutions de se développer
donc vous les interpellez c'est
politique avec donc dans votre buzza
c'est 50 solutions appliquez tout de
suite j'insiste à 50 recommandations
et vous les êtes rencontrés manuel
Macron la Premier ministre madame borne
les députés les sénateurs Valérie
Pécresse président de la Région
Île-de-France vous êtes senti une marque
d'intérêt au minimum un intérêt fort
voire plus parce qu'on se dit ils vous
ont reçu parce que vous êtes Bertrand
Picard et que pour leur image c'est bon
de s'afficher avec vous quelle est la
sincérité dans leur démarche alors vous
savez je m'attendais à être très bien
reçu par les écologistes et par la
gauche en disant voilà on va pouvoir
pousser des solutions sur le plan
législatif et en fait qui se sont le
plus intéressés ces centres droites et
droites c'est les républicains c'est
Renaissance c'est à ce niveau là et je
m'attendais pas à ce que ce soit eux qui
poussent autant les solutions
Valérie Pécresse s'est arrangé pour qui
est 5 amendements déposés à la loi au
projet de loi sur l'énergie en prenant 5
recommandations du prêt à voter donc en
fait il y a eu beaucoup d'intérêts mais
ça venait pas forcément d'où je pensais
et je n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
d'être auditionné par la gauche par les
écologistes sur les commissions des
autres parties qui m'ont auditionné
c'est assez curieux mais enfin c'est
comme ça on peut faire déjà Bertrand
Picard un petit bilan
peut-être tiens sur la région
Île-de-France on se dit quoi vous avez
proposé les les datacenter des solutions
une solution pour rendre les Data Center
plus propre elle a pas été retenue je
crois cette proposition non mais
regardez c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
étonnant il y a bon il y a
des recommandations qui ont été
intégrées c'est la grivevoltaïsme et le
solaire flottant ça c'est dans le dans
le projet de loi dans le projet de loi
non mais on demande non non alors à la
région c'est clair que ça va être
utilisé Valérie Pécresse et passionné
par ces solutions Jean rotner à la
région Grand Est également mais il y a
eu des amendements qui ont été amenés au
Parlement pour que certaines de ces
recommandations puissent intégrer la loi
notamment que la chaleur des Data Center
puisse être utilisée pour chauffer des
villes et que les émanations de méthane
des décharges publics puissent être
récupérées pour être réutilisé comme
énergie à la place du gaz russe
c'est quand même extraordinaire de voir
que ces deux amendements ont été refusés
parce que
les arguments c'est de toute façon on
veut diminuer les décharges publics donc
on va pas récupérer le méthane des
décharges publics je vois pas le rapport
l'autre amendement sur les Data Center a
été refusé parce que le but est d'avoir
des Data Center qui chauffent moins mais
il y a quand même la chaleur à récupérer
donc en fait il y a une logique dans le
monde politique qui m'échappe clairement
on amène des solutions qui sont
économiquement rentables qui peuvent
tout de suite entrer en fonction qui
sont crédibles qui créent des emplois
qui améliorent la qualité de vie et puis
on les retient pas pourquoi c'est
blocages alors parce que pour arriver à
débloquer quelque chose il y a beaucoup
de règles administratives à changer de
règle bureaucratique à changer et je
vais vous dire une chose il y a quand
même pas mal de gens qui pensent que
c'est plus simple de rien changer que de
changer quelque chose que c'est plus
facile et je pense que ce qui va
détruire la planète c'est pas non
seulement la pollution c'est la paresse
et la paralysie et la complaisance on
croit qu'on fait déjà mobilismes et on
fait absolument pas assez quelles sont
les propositions qui ont été retenues
Bertrand Picard notamment dans ce dans
le projet de loi dans la loi désormais
sur les énergies renouvelables il y a eu
l'installation des panneaux solaires
flottants oui ça ça a été retenu ou ça
ça a été retenu et heureusement parce
que vous avez une entreprise comme
accuoénergique est une entreprise
française qui a mis à peu près 10 ans
pour installer des panneaux solaires
flottants sur la carte artificiel à
l'acte de carrière en fait dans le
Vaucluse
10 ans pour ça vous savez les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas que du solaire
et du vent
c'est aussi d'hydroélectrique de petites
rivières c'est mettre dans des rivières
des des petites turbines entraînées par
l'eau qui produisent de l'électricité
pour un village et ça c'est pas un
problème pour les poissons parce qu'on
prend pas toute la rivière c'est aussi
la géothermie c'est pouvoir brancher des
pompes à chaleur sur des puits
géothermiques à 180 mètres de profondeur
ça aussi il faut des facilités
administratives parce que sinon on
arrive rien à bouger on avance pas et
donc ces solutions qui auraient mérité
d'être intégrées pour le coup
à cette à cette loi ce projet de loi sur
les anneauxbles ça a pas été le cas vous
êtes déçu oui parce que cette loi est
fragmentaire elle est lacunaire il faut
vous savez ça sert à rien de vouloir
produire plus d'énergie même
renouvelable tant qu'on continue à
gaspiller l'énergie avec des systèmes
qui sont complètement inefficients avec
des lampadaires d'éclairage public qui
ont même pas d'ampoule LED et des choses
comme ça aujourd'hui si vous mettiez des
ampoules LED
partout où il n'y en a pas encore en
France ça équivaudrait à la production
énergétique de quatre centrales
nucléaires
c'est l'énergie qu'il faut pour faire
rouler 7 millions de voitures
électriques pourquoi ça n'a pas été
accepté ça
à voter
je sais pas demandé leur invité leur
invités
vous allez les voir les députés les
sénateurs
certains sont très intéressants à
comprendre encore une fois le blocage
ils nous disent que c'est une initiative
de démocratie participative qu'ils
aiment beaucoup ça qui qu'on va aller
faire de des auditions avec toutes les
commissions avec davantage de
parlementaires etc puis on attend puis
on attend puis on demande des
invitations par les parler alors c'est
50 solutions elles ont été retenues
parmi donc on a dit les 1450 labellisés
par la Fondation solar in pulse pour
protéger l'environnement elles sont
applicables réplicables à l'échelle
nationale elles sont rentables et
exemple vous allez voir avec deux
innovations on est dans l'univers de la
voiture mais aussi des fameux panneaux
solaires flottants dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure reportage signé manuels
pollution réchauffement climatique fonte
des glaces un compte à rebours s'est
enclenché notre planète est sur le fil
il faut agir vite et pour cela des
solutions il en existerait quelques-unes
selon la Fondation solar inpols 1400
initiatives concrètes prêtent à l'emploi
pourraient permettre à notre planète de
sortir la tête de l'eau
[Musique]
parmi elles Logico à Mérignac près de
Bordeaux cette entreprise s'est fixé
pour objectif d'aider à moindre coût les
automobilistes à réaliser leurs
transition écologique
le transport représente 23% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde dont 40% proviennent uniquement
des voitures et ces chiffres ne font
qu'augmenter il y a de plus en plus de
moteur thermique sur la planète d'ici
2027 28 on aura plus de 2 milliards de
véhicules thermiques sur terre alors que
le Parlement européen a voté
l'interdiction pour les constructeurs de
vendre des véhicules thermiques à partir
de 2035 la flotte déjà existante
pourrait mettre encore quelques années à
disparaître avant d'être remplacé par
des voitures électriques alors comment
cohabiter avec tout en diminuant leur
impact sur la planète la solution se
trouverait dans cette petite boîte
alors ce produit c'est très simple c'est
la Blue iBox de Logico on peut la mettre
sur n'importe quel moteur thermique ou
essence son but essentiel ça va être de
réduire la pollution on va diviser
quasiment par deux la pollution parfois
on a été jusqu'à plus on a des véhicules
que nous avons équipés ou on a réduit
par plus de 98 % l'opacité du moteur
donc vraiment une réduction drastique de
la pollution le principe est simple
cette boîte contient de l'eau
déminéralisée et donc de l'hydrogène la
molécule est injectée dans le moteur ce
qui lui permet de réaliser une
combustion parfaite et de réduire sa
production de CO2 en moyenne il faut
compter 1000 euros pour l'équipement et
l'installation c'est une alternative
durant le temps de la transition
écologique pour que les gens qui n'ont
pas les moyens de s'acheter aujourd'hui
un véhicule électrique qui peut coûter
plus cher ou qui peut ne pas
correspondre d'un point de vue de
l'autonomie du véhicule à leurs besoins
et une solution aujourd'hui Logico ne
compte pas s'arrêter là les ingénieurs
planchent sur une version
Excel de ces boîtiers dans le but
d'équiper les poids lourds responsables
de 6% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en Europe d'ailleurs la Commission
européenne pourrait interdire la vente
de camions et bus polluants d'ici 2040
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique il faut agir sur différents
leviers comme par exemple la production
d'énergie verte se passer des énergies
fossiles c'est se tourner vers les
éoliennes sur terre mais aussi en mer
les panneaux photovoltaïques se sont
également répandus sur les toits de nos
maisons de nos hangar dans les champs
mais aussi sur l'eau
[Musique]
nous avons rendez-vous en banlieue de
l'île chez ciel et terre depuis 2006
l'entreprise est spécialisée dans
l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques flottant dans les
bassins artificiels elle compte 270
projets dont plus de 30 pays par Le
Soler flottant un des gros avantages
c'est le refroidissement naturel des
panneaux qui permet de gagner en
productivité de gagner en efficience le
deuxième point c'est de limiter
l'évaporation aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de sécheresse mais l'un des
points qui touche le plus le citoyen
c'est l'impact de l'installation sur
l'environnement sur terre certaines
forêts et zones naturelles sont
détruites pour faire place à plusieurs
hectares de panneaux solaires mais qu'en
est-il des installations flottantes
on est moins confronté en termes
d'acceptation dont concernant le solaire
flottant tout simplement parce que on
vient pas modifier la nature du site en
tout cas on l'a modifie pas
fondamentalement enfin de vie on est
capable de tout simplement retirer ces
flotteurs de l'eau et laisser le site
tel qu'il était initialement
les étendues d'eau sélectionnés pour
l'installation de panneaux solaires
flottants sont rarement exploitables par
l'humain il s'agit très souvent de
barrage hydroélectriques de bassin
d'irrigation ou encore de lacs de
carrière et minier
le potentiel aujourd'hui en France c'est
d'à peu près d'un peu plus de 20 GW
sachant que un instant t il doit y avoir
que quelques centaines de mégawatts
installés donc on a encore de belles
perspectives en France la France ne
manque donc pas détendu d'eau douce mais
pour anticiper l'avenir la loi
accélération climat vient de faciliter
ce type d'installation flottante dans le
domaine public maritime naturel
[Musique]
Bertrand Picard vous en pensez quoi
alors vous êtes à la source de ces deux
innovations comment vous avez retenu
d'ailleurs ces deux-là il y a eu un
filtre comment ça s'est passé alors les
solutions sont présentées à nos experts
on a un groupe de 370 experts
indépendants qui examinent selon les
critères qu'on a donné donc crédibilité
application immédiate rentabilité
écologique et frein qui doit être levés
des freins qui doivent être levés mais
ça c'est pas les experts qui qui
décident de ça c'est le premier filtre
c'est le premier filtre pour donner le
label et notre label est le seul la
belle actuellement au monde qui est
certifie la rentabilité économique d'un
produit ou d'un système ou d'un matériau
ou d'un appareil qui protège
l'environnement c'est vrai que c'est 50
solutions elles pourraient selon vous
décarbonez de 30 à 40 % notre pays si on
les appliquait toutes oui c'est ce qu'on
a calculé avec avec nos experts
et c'est colossal et c'est pour ça qu'il
y a aucune raison de pas le faire parce
que c'est pas un sacr on demande pas à
l'état des subsides pour payer les
utilisateurs ou les innovateurs on
demande simplement de de modifier la
réglementation ou la législation pour
que ça puisse se faire plus rapidement
vous souhaite inscrire dans la loi un
objectif de valorisation de 75 % des
déchets non dangereux à horizon 2025
c'est ça oui parce qu'en fait l'idée
c'est que avec ce prête à voter je leur
ai expliqué vous mettez en avant des
solutions proposées par des industriels
pour qu'elles soient ensuite
généralisées en étant inscrit dans la
loi française ça que vous faites
exactement explication donc encore une
fois et en même temps j'ai envie de vous
dire beaucoup vont vous dire que c'est
pas possible de faire ça de cet objectif
de valorisation de 75% des déchets non
dangereux et raison 2025
issus d'ailleurs souvent des chantiers
de construction et vous donc dans votre
besoin aussi dit que faire du tour du
monde en avion solaire serait impossible
aux pensées que faire voler un ballon
autour du monde sans escale c'était
impossible vous savez moi j'adore ces
changements de paradigme qui permettent
de prendre un qui paraît immuable et
changer quelques quelques paramètres à
l'intérieur pour montrer que c'est
possible et cette histoire de déchets
c'était pas possible jusqu'à maintenant
mais ça l'ai maintenant exactement il y
a une entreprise qui permet de le faire
dans votre besace ce procédé conçu par
la société néolith qui transforme ces
fameux gravats en pierre comme quoi
c'est possible on regarde tout de suite
qu'elle se procédé et on se retrouve
juste après
en France 40 millions de tonnes de
déchets non recyclables sont enfouis ou
incinérés chaque année chez néolith on
propose de les fossiliser pour en faire
des granulés de construction minéralisez
nos déchets c'est le défi relevé par
néolith qui propose un procédé insolite
de fossilisation de nos détritus on va
prendre ces déchets là ils vont être
convoyés jusqu'à tout un système de
broyage ici qui va nous permettre
d'obtenir une poudre inférieure à 500
microns de déchets ensuite cette poudre
sera amalgamée avec un liant très
particulier de notre composition ce
mélange poudre liant sera pressé et
extrudé pour
et on va en faire des granulats qui
pourront être utilisés notamment dans
cette construction l'innovation ouvre à
présent de nouvelles perspectives le
projet pour 2023 recycler nos poubelles
domestiques
pouvoir transformer les ordures
ménagères dans leur globalité donc nous
on voit fossilisation comme une nouvelle
filière industrielle tendrait à venir
remplacer entièrement l'enfouissement et
l'incinération une solution simple qui
pourrait enfin réconcilier l'écologie et
l'activité industrielle si on pouvait
traiter l'ensemble des ordures ménagères
françaises on pourrait réduire de 5%
l'impact carbone français donc tout
industrie confondu c'est à peu près deux
fois l'équivalent du transport aérien
donc c'est considéré
[Musique]
reportage donc signé maxcours valorisé
donc 75% de nos déchets issus des
chantiers de construction à horizon 2025
donc c'est réalisable on vient de le
voir néolith la prouver après la
question que je me pose c'est est-ce que
c'est réplicable à l'échelle nationale
alors totalement totalement et on peut
aller même encore plus loin maintenant
il y a une des solutions labellisées qui
est une plateforme d'échange pour
déchets de construction de manière à ce
que au lieu de jeter les déchets dans
les décharges publics on puisse les
utiliser directement sous forme de
gravats recyclé pour le béton et
aujourd'hui des sociétés comme Olsen
lafargeons SIM arrive à utiliser 100% de
déchets recyclés pour faire du béton et
bien la loi permet entre 5 et 50%
maximum parce qu'il y a le principe de
le principe de précaution aux yeux
oulala c'est nouveau etc mais
prouvons que c'est possible prouvant
qu'on peut le faire et ensuite
encourageons là mais cette manière de
retenir les choses quand on sait la
charge de carbone incroyable qu'il y a
dans la fabrication de bâtiments avec du
ciment carboné et du béton neuf on voit
que maintenant on peut déjà utiliser du
ciment partiellement des carboné et du
béton qui vient de du recyclage donc il
faut que il faut vraiment que les
législateurs maintenant
ouvrent les yeux sur ce qui existe parce
que la progression des solutions par
rapport à il y a 5 ans est exponentielle
il y a 5 ans j'aurais jamais pu vous
dire tout ça aujourd'hui je peux et dans
5 ans si tout ça n'est pas appliqué et
bien ce sera trop tard au niveau
d'urgence climatique dans ce contexte
d'inflation et de flamber des prix
l'énergie de ce point d'achat et
durablement impacté vous proposez aussi
dans ce prête à voter des solutions
concrètes pour y faire face qui
réduisent aussi la facture je pense à
celle-ci énergie une pompe à chaleur
pour les pour les immeubles qui divisent
la facture par 5 oui oui on fait coup
double mais mais exactement vous pouvez
utiliser des puits géothermiques 180
mètres de profondeur
cette technique là vient d'une
entreprise pétrolière qui se recycle
c'est schumberger de voir que maintenant
il faut qu'ils aillent forer pour de la
chaleur plutôt que simplement pour du
pétrole il branche des pompes à chaleur
sur ce réseau géothermique et vous
pouvez non plus comme autrefois chauffer
seulement des maisons individuelles en
banlieue vous pouvez chauffer des
immeubles de grande taille dans les
centres villes et ça c'est une
révolution en termes de chauffage et
comme vous le dites c'est tout à fait
juste c'est une facture d'énergie
divisée par 5 alors vous avez bien
investissement au départ c'est vrai un
investissement de l'argent qu'on met
pour n'obtenir plus et maintenant il
commence à y avoir des nouveaux systèmes
de financement qui se mettent en
œuvre pour
vendre la chaleur plutôt que vendre la
pompe à chaleur donc les gens ont des
pompes à chaleur qui peuvent être
installés comme ça ils payent chaque
mois leur chaleur beaucoup moins cher
que si c'était du gaz ou du ou du fioul
ou juste des l'électricité normale dans
un radiateur électrique et puis ils
n'ont pas d'investissement à faire ils
payent simplement leur facture de cette
manière-là
que vous avez reçu pour cette solution
mais quand vous parlez aux gens ils ont
tous laissé de lui et puis quand vous
demandez qui est des facilitations
administratives tout à coup tout le
monde se renvoie la balle et puis il y a
pas grand chose qui bouge alors
heureusement cette solution là elle
arrive à se développer quand même parce
qu'elle est tellement spectaculaire que
même sans faciliter administrative ils
arrivent à s'y retrouver à s'implanter
de mieux en mieux et il y a maintenant
une une association sur la bioénergie
qu'il se crée en France justement sur
toute l'énergie qu'on arrive à attirer
de la du sol ou de la géo énergie je
crois que c'est comme ça il y a plein
d'initiatives c'est génial ces solutions
mais votre initiative et je souhaite
évidemment qu'elle soit cornée de succès
elle me rappelle un peu pour l'instant
et la vient de le dira parce que vous
prenez votre bâton de pèlerin et vous
allez faire les sénateurs et voilà c'est
votre combat du moment cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat en France 150
citoyens français ira au sort qui est
formulé des propositions de loi
finalement 10% ont été retenus est-ce
que le risque pour vous mais vous le
prenez vous avez raison c'est qu'on se
retrouve finalement aussi avec quelques
mesures prises et pas suffisamment au
regard de ce qu'il faut pour qu'on
réussisse à sauver la planète la grande
différence c'est que la convention
citoyenne n'avait pas proposé des
solutions techniques qu'ils avaient
proposé surtout des changements de
comportement
et ça c'est toujours beaucoup plus
conflictuel si vous interdisez la
publicité vous vous heurtez aux médias
qui ne vivent que par la publicité ça
c'était une des propositions de la
convention citoyenne donc c'est clair
que c'était clivant que ce soit juste ou
faux c'est équivant
nous ce qu'on veut c'est faire du
gagnant-gagnant entre l'économie et
l'écologie par des solutions techniques
qui existent et qu'on peut implémenter
pour rester optimiste sur le fait qu'on
puisse encore sauver la planète et
limiter sous 2 degrés le réchauffement
climatique d'ici 2100 alors pour moi
l'optimisme ne sert à rien passionné
optimiste on se dit de toute façon ça
ira bien il y a rien besoin de faire et
pessimiste ne sert à rien parce qu'on se
dit toute façon c'est foutu donc il y a
rien à faire donc je pense qu'il faut
être réaliste elle réalise c'est quand
on sort de son idéologie personnelle
pour aller prendre un peu partout tout
ce dont on a besoin pour obtenir un
résultat et ce qui disent Bertrand
Picard qui la décroissance économique
c'est le meilleur moyen de respecter les
engagements climatiques est-ce que vous
répondez je dis qu'il faut décroître la
pollution il faut décroître la démesure
faut décroître le gaspillage il faut des
Croates line efficience oui ça oui mais
décroître l'économie ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous avez moins
d'argent à redistribuer
pour l'éducation pour la solidarité pour
la santé pour la sécurité sociale pour
les retraites c'est est-ce que c'est ça
qui j'en veulent et puis moi je vous dis
aussi que la décroissance économique
c'est un problème de riche parce que
vous allez voir dans les pays en
développement qui représentent quand
même la majorité du monde allez leur
parler décroissance et économique quand
ils arrivent déjà pas à se nourrir et à
s'éduquer c'est
pour vous donner une idée de ce que
c'est que la croissance et la
décroissance pour
héberger les nouveaux venus sur terre
dans les 20 prochaines années plus le
résultat de l'exode rural dans les
villes il faut construire tous les
quatre mois tous les quatre mois
l'équivalent d'une ville comme Manhattan
alors elle est où la décroissance donc
c'est pas la décroissance économique
qu'il faut il faut utiliser maintenant
toutes les solutions techniques qui
existent mais qui existe maintenant pas
celle du futur hypothétique celle qui
existe maintenant et il y en a pour que
toute cette toutes ces constructions
tous ces nouveaux venus sur Terre et ne
crée pas un impact désastreux sur
l'environnement à ceux qui disent
Bertrand Picard est formidable mais la
technologie pour sauver la planète c'est
un doux rêve il faudra changer les
comportements de la sobriété et que tout
ne peut pas reposer sur les innovations
et la technologie vous leur répondez
quoi je réponds que c'est tout à fait
juste que c'est pas la technologie qui
va sauver la planète c'est ce qu'on a en
fera et alors maintenant la sobriété et
l'efficience je vous donne un exemple si
vous demandez de la sobriété aux gens et
de passer de 21 degrés de chauffage à 19
degrés ok ils vont gagner 14 % sur la
facture énergétique et sur les émissions
de CO2 maintenant ils mettent une pompe
à chaleur avec un puits géothermique il
divise par 5 leurs émissions de CO2
il divise par 5 leur
facture énergétique et il y a des moyens
de financement maintenant qui font qu'on
a plus besoin de payer sa pompe à
chaleur on peut avoir une installation
de pompe à chaleur et on paye que la
chaleur produite au pays l'usage
lieu de payer le produit donc on reste
déterminé ni pessimiste ni optimisme et
déterminée avancer absolument merci pour
cette entretien passionnant Bertrand
Piccard donc invité spéciale de pourvu
que ça dure merci à vous avec plaisir
merci de l'invitation c'est la fin donc
de pourvu que ça dure l'émission qui
rend les correspondances sur Public
Sénat émission à voir ou revoir sur
public anal le replay je vous le
rappelle c'est public sena.fr
rendez-vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]